come on keep moving keep moving get up
get it done don't you stop keep going it
is a one of a kind show get off i'm
eddie hall will strongest man 2017.
these guys have been through the
struggles all different shapes all
different sizes but they're coming to me
looking to change their lives for the
better
you've seen transformations but you
haven't seen transformations like this
you're gonna absolutely beast the [ __ ]
out of these guys
my name is jake ramirez aka mr fabulous
i'm here to be beasted and turned from
jabba the heart
into an adonis
[Music]
hey how you doing i'm good man how are
you
oh you'll excuse me man i'm not in my
like glamorous glitch you know
yeah i didn't even moisturize my legs
i'm eating fitness royalty
what's going on with you right now are
you not training are you too busy with
your work
it's all good looking fabulous but then
underneath all that there's a whole car
crash going on and i just want to sort
it out do you know what i mean
luke and chris are you around this is my
team wow
these two are my right and left first
thing i like to do with the participants
is
get your top off let's do your body fats
and see what we're working with brace
yourself
boys shatter the mirrors
is this a scar across here jeez
[Music]
i've always been an unconventional
quirky type of guy as you can see
but sadly at the age of 17 i was
cornered by seven guys
and brutally attacked and ended up in a
hospital fighting for my life
i've come i've come out the other side
you see i i'm the thing with me is i've
always been one of those people i'm not
gonna let
something like that beat me yeah man
it's uh a bad point it's tough
sorry just getting it no it's all right
man what that scar
shows me is that you're a fighter and a
survivor that's that's that's what it
[Music]
says
all right you ready for the first one
straight into the deep end
that looks heavy during the fashion can
you help luke with his trainers
can you grow his hair as well i'm
basically the english rock
[Music]
fantastic i think there's a bit more in
there
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
six weeks time we're gonna smash that at
the park
[Music]
gonna get lower
[Music]
[Applause]
fantastic
honestly buddy nothing to be ashamed of
me four reps is good
[Music]
you know when they carry the water or
stuff yeah
boom it's quite easy to forget that you
are 40 years old
feeling okay you've done really well
really really well you've got the
willpower to go on and push
and that's what we need from you now for
the next six weeks is to push through
those barriers
right train right we'll come back and
you're gonna
[Music]
knight degree to your right mate you've
been absolutely phenomenal
i'm not gonna let you guys down trust me
i don't think you will this is the big
one
buddy come on cheers buddy see you later
um
what an awesome guy jane's story is i
mean it just displays the fact that the
human character
can like push through adversity no scars
man he should wear with pride
i'm hungry
well guys it's the first morning of my
nutritional breakfast
chin chin up
now this is adorable
[Music]
which is driving me freaking crazy do
you think that maybe you can take a
little bit from
from what you're seeing and you know
maybe cut down on the alcohol and maybe
cut down on the carbs a little bit
no aj i've been following your progress
and it looks like you've been smashing
it
i'm sending chris and luke to check up
on you and give you some support
big love the beast so come on luke let
me just
uh yeah introduce you to my secret
garden
so the first week i lost uh four kilos
yeah you know right now i feel that i've
lost like 10 years yeah so i better tell
people i'm not 40 anymore
so how have you found the training i
went on my own first straight away like
i got intimidated someone came up to me
and said i bet you want to look as good
as me yeah
and then i called up my friend georgia
and i said george i can't do this on my
own i need a gym buddy i got a gym buddy
what's your motivation now mate i've
just got this vision in my head of
how i want to be and where i want to be
i've never cooked for a bodybuilder
before but you know there's always a
guy you cook for me many times yeah
you're not being a bodybuilder it's a
starter luke
[Laughter]
thank you very mate
you much at me should have thought about
that shouldn't you
this is my cabinet of accolades a bit
like meryl streep 2012
um i won the the pride of britain real
just in the dumbell on its own
what did you receive that for obviously
i got over my attack
then i decided to give back to the
community and i went out to
rebuild confidence with people that have
lost their confidence through singing
maybe i've gotten in the beast mentality
and i don't even realize it
and i have to keep looking around at the
things that i've achieved and things
that have accumulated over the years
and that will give me that strength
you ain't capable you're just a princess
my husband just like give it up go back
to eating pizza in prosecco and whatever
and just
just let them away
[Music]
i i really i need to think
whether i want to continue with this or
not
[Music]
because right now i really just feel
like packing it in
try to catch me all in that
hey jay how are you buddy the last few
days i've been
really upset and almost wanted to just
kind of like
say this and what's the point listen man
i mean on my
on my journey of becoming the world's
strongest man i had a lot of haters a
lot of people saying i couldn't do it a
lot of people saying
you'll never win the world's strongest
man you're fat you're ugly i use it as
fuel put it all in that fire
and burn it up and put that fire in your
belly and get angry and put it into the
gym
so mr fabulous uh i mean he's always
almost as he's in presenter mode all the
time he puts this front on this brave
face and you can see behind that brave
face he does struggle
you know he struggles with his
confidence a little bit and i think he's
gonna do really well throughout the
tasks
but i can tell that jay's struggling
well can you believe it i've actually
made it to the last week i can't wait
for all the haters to swallow
the beauty and just observe
take it in admire and keep from hating
[Music]
babies
[Music]
how has jay been the last few weeks i
have to be honest and say that
he surprised me because
i have been no help whatsoever i still
been drinking i've been eating my carbs
and that proves how strong he is really
it does
[Music]
whoa
guys how is it done uh seven and a half
kilogram weight drop
five percent body fat off you look
younger thank you you look healthier
your skin looks better
literally are glowing right well luckily
for you
we've decided to only point you through
the weakest test which we believe
was the bench press if i remember
rightly your last time you hear chris
what was his tv
45 right what we're seeing guys going to
get this
yay come on buddy i've done this before
lightweight come on let's get it it's
only 40 kilos
press good luck yeah
okay i've got a surprise for you mate do
you want to know how much you just
pressed
53 kilos
i lied to you because i knew it was in
your head yeah it's like a 25
strength increase which is pretty big
so i suppose there's nothing left to do
but to get you up and get that top off
[Applause]
i mean we can see the improvement how do
you feel i feel great i mean
say about a week and a half ago i was
all kind of like doled up
coming back from an event and some guy
across the road started heckling
abuse at me yeah saying was you know
he's gonna come and beat me up and stuff
but for for the first time i kind of
felt
that if me and him went into a boxing
room i'll probably knock him out having
straight sets to me you're redefining
strength because
you're battling things head-on you know
you've been through so much in your life
who cares what people say who cares what
people think you've got you
you've got your fella you've got your
friends you've got your family that's
all you need
[Music]
i feel great i'm not gonna lie with
regards to my scars
it's always going to be there but what i
want to show people is
beneath all this fabulous exterior
glitz and glamour there is substance and
boy there is a lot of strength
take it or leave it i will never
compromise with my fabulous attitude
i know you shouldn't have favorites but
jay
he's he's my boy james he came to get
beasted
and he got beasted yeah
you